[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people become wealthy
do work that they really love
and create actual amazing relationships
ramsey personalities are always on the
air with me today george campbell ramsey
personality host of the
uh fine print podcast and also
participating with rachel cruz and i
tonight in our live stream
on the real estate reality check we are
looking out our studio windows if you're
listening to us this is uh july the 14th
and we'll be doing that event tonight
we're looking through all the equipment
tonight that'll be used that we're
actually going to use our our lobby as
our studio for the streaming and so all
the equipment's out there and it feels
like 48 million miles of cable just to
run this thing
and our normal audience that's up close
to the uh screen has been pushed back
into the another county out there way
back there guys and yeah so they're
having to watch from back there and um
probably helpful for
how how good looking you and i are we
look better from back there it
definitely helps they can dim the lights
it'd be even better so if you want to
join us tonight for the uh live stream
the real estate reality check george
rachel and i will be talking for about
an hour and uh we hope you can join us
it is a free event and we're gonna be
talking about the real estate market uh
what's happening with inflation
recession house prices interest rates
all of that and uh and what's not
happening too and what's not happening
yeah is it going to crash is it going to
crash is it going to crash spoiler alert
we're going to tell you it's not but
we're going to actually deal with a lot
of we're going to have a little bit of a
college class a little charge i've never
seen so many graphs and charts in my
life but we make them fun you're going
to wear a tweet jacket and go full
professor on us and i can't wait no i'm
not i'm not wearing a tweed jacket just
don't leave us to be a little elbow
patches
does that mean i would have tenure you
will have tenure oh there you go i've
always wanted that yeah i don't even
know what it means still but it sounds
cool it means you can't get fired even
if you're stupid wow that's what tenure
means i see why people want it so badly
we've proven that with something can i
get some of the college professors i had
proved that yeah do you offer that here
at ramsey no we do not we do not have
that we don't have tenure so ramsey
solutions dot com slash reality check
join us tonight it is a free event
andrea starts off this hour in dallas
texas hey andrea welcome to the ramsay
show
oh dave it's good to talk to you again
youtube thank you for having me on your
show well thank you um
i don't know you probably i don't know
if you remember i actually met you back
in 2019 at your studio my husband and i
stopped by and i i i'm a balloon artist
i made a bunch of balloons for your
grandkids oh thank you
thank you i'm darling i'm sorry i met so
many people i can't remember my name so
but i'm glad you're here how can we
help okay well i was hoping you could
help me with a little disagreement i'm
having with my husband um
we've been married 10 years and i
have listened to you longer and got him
on to the
uh the total money makeover and we
followed you and we're able to get debt
free good and
we like it he likes it a lot
and but now we are having um
our second baby
due in november and he's having to work
from home and i'm nesting
and we feel like it's time to move up in
house and we have a little bit of a
disagreement i feel like i found like
the ideal dream house and he feels like
it's too much
and um
it would it would cause us to have a
mortgage again for a little while and he
just he just doesn't want to do that
and i'm just like
don't feel like i want to settle when
we're going to be in the house hopefully
a long time
so um
that's okay so what is your current home
worth
um we are hoping after realtor fees that
we can get about three hundred thousand
dollars out of it um and what would the
other house
cost the other house that we're looking
at
our realtor thinks we could get it if we
made an offer for 4.95
so a move of 200 000 do you have any
money saved above the 300
we do we've got our emergency fund of 16
grand which we're not going to touch
correct and then in other various
accounts we've managed to save up about
a little over a hundred grand okay so
you're only a hundred thousand dollars
in disagreement
basically yeah if you had another 100k
would he be okay with the 500 000 house
he would be thrilled with it his thing
is like so some of these things it's not
too much house it's no debt that he
wants
right it's not too much house it's not
there's no debt he says this house is
fancy it's a want it's not a need we
shouldn't go into debt for a want okay
and um
okay i i
got it i got it and so what's your
household income
2021 we did a combined 101 000
how quickly can you save a hundred grand
i don't know
um
we
i mean if we
less than three years probably
two to three years two and a half years
maybe two to three years
maybe no definitely projected to do
definitely
if you had to do it to save your life
you could save a hundred grand in two
years but three you could definitely do
it
okay because you'd be living on beans
and rice again in order to hit this goal
to do two years
three years you can definitely do it
okay
or you can pick up do you have anything
else you can sell
oh
not nothing that's like worth much i
mean
you got expensive cars
no they're they're used cars and they
are
paid off and they're
you know kind of old
they're not expensive okay what about
going to a 400 000 house and you pay
cash for it
have you looked into what that would
look like
we've um
we're still looking and keeping our eyes
open we haven't ruled it out
um
okay so here's the deal
what we're really arguing about is not
whether you have too much house if i'm
understanding your outline what you're
really arguing about is the hundred is
whether we go in debt or not
right and your husband's going i finally
got free
i can't walk willingly into another bear
trap i can't do it i can't i can't
swallow the bill as much as i love you
as much as i want you to have what you
want i just can't go back there it makes
me throw up into my mouth
right and then part of me is also like
inflation is going up and what if i buy
too much house and then like
the country's going crazy and then i
can't like feed no you don't have to
worry about that you don't worry about
that what you've got to worry about what
you can control
your bottom line is you guys are arguing
about a hundred grand and two to three
years
that's what you're arguing about you're
not really arguing about whether to move
if moving is valid whether the 500 000
house is too big a house
uh whether
we're really not arguing about any of
those things we're just a hundred grand
short of doing what you want to do and
you're willing to go in debt and he's
not
correct that's what it comes down to
and so once you quantify it that way it
gives you some real good
points for discussion um i don't think
either one of you are in the stupid zone
with this if you took out a little
mortgage and paid it off real fast it
doesn't violate our guidelines
but i've got to personally agree with
your husband once i got out of debt you
weren't going to drag me back in kicking
screaming under any circumstances there
wasn't anything sharon wanted bad enough
for me to do that or i wanted bad enough
for me to do that ever
and i was actually more likely to want
something than she was
but you couldn't get me to do it again
so i kind of understand where your
husband's coming from i don't think
george and i have an answer for there's
no one right or wrong here you guys have
to get on the same page whatever you do
going forward and i don't think you're
buying this house unless you both come
into agreement that's for sure
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
talking about your life and your money
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five pete is in
boston hey pete how are you
how are you dave thank you again for
taking my call i talked to you about 18
months ago i followed your advice about
paying off my mortgage and you're right
the grass grasses really does feel
greener
your peace of mind the peace of mind is
priceless but i did have another
question dave
i'm 65 i'm 65 years old i have around
2.4
million in
between 401 and ira
i also have uh individual stocks and
taxable mutual funds worth about 520.
i just uh sold an inherited house and i
have about 140
000
and my question to you is i don't have
any roth account none of my assets are
in roth and
i'm wondering at this stage of the game
at my age should i be getting involved
with raw should i use some of this money
from the
house to pay the federal tax to
uh to roll some of it to rock yeah how
old are you again yeah
uh 65 going to be 66.
i probably wouldn't fool with it um you
can if you want
here's the benefit yeah all right let's
say let's say that you move 400 000 to
roth and you use this hunt and you use a
hundred thousand to pay the taxes
okay
now you've got a hundred thousand
dollars that from this point forward
will grow
tax
free
now that's not going having traded a
hundred for tax-free
growth is not going to come out until it
grows by more than 100.
yes yeah yeah and so you've got you
would have to commit to leave that
particular account alone
probably until death
and just let just let her let it be
inherited
okay i i guess my well well that was
part of my concern is that i have three
children it would be inherited tax free
for them but i guess my concern is when
rmds come along yeah and it'll help with
that too it'll help with rmds
so that portion would not be subject to
rmds but it won't grow
enough tax-free dollars
for
a good decade anyway
to have justified yeah okay
so
if you're going to leave it alone at
least 10 years and it sounds like you
don't need the money you've got enough
other money
yes
so you could you could do it i mean
there's no harm in it
and it does help with rmds and it does
help with inheritance and it does help
with the fact that the money you know
after that decade or so
but you could say okay how fast is that
400 gonna grow or how long does it take
that 400 to grow to enough
that the growth
saves me a hundred thousand dollars in
taxes because i've already paid it
yeah
it'd be close to a decade
yeah so it's something you wouldn't
necessarily do if you were in my
business you would or i would i would if
you're going to commit to not touching
this particular account for over a
decade okay
okay okay
okay
all right that's that i needed to know
that ironically just one other thing
i have a 401k and there's about a one
six in the 401k i got about 600 in the
other one in the ira and the ira is the
one i have a financial advisor uh
and it's down almost double what my 401k
is and i and i know this is a you have
to wait this mark it out but it's just
amazing yeah
and when you pay attention out of this
2.6 million at 65 years old did you
start out or did you inherit a lot of
money or did you start out with a lot of
money or how did you get this
no i i
this is from working uh putting money
away all my life i inherited about six
hundred thousand taxable
that and and the house after you were
already a millionaire or did that make
you a millionaire oh yes oh yeah oh yeah
long after okay so you were already a
millionaire and then you inherited money
yeah so you're not a millionaire because
of inherited money okay interesting i
always just want to verify that because
there's lots of these guys out here all
across america and for those of you that
are so stupid that you think everybody
inherits their wealth it almost never
happens statistically
very few less than 10 of americans
become wealthy are are
exclusively become millionaires because
of and we've got data to prove that
because of that and so when they become
wealthy and you say stupid butt stuff
like you're so lucky
luck didn't have squat to do with it
that's like looking at the farmer who
just had corn grow and say you're saying
lackey after he planted the freaking
corn yeah pete didn't win the lottery to
get here he just consistently invested
over a long period of time and now he's
got these kinds of options it's amazing
but sounds like he can do it but not for
the roi benefits mathematically but more
for some other benefits with the rmds
and being able to pass it on yeah the
roi will be there probably in seven to
ten years that's what we're saying
but um but the the trick is that the
tax-free part has to offset the part
that you put that money up front
and so it takes about a decade for that
to work out i've done all of mine years
ago but knowing that i wasn't going to
touch it i'll probably never touch any
of those accounts last time yeah and so
all of them be everything i have is in
roth now i've converted it all and paid
the taxes and i even even the matching
portion that comes in we we converted
and pay the taxes uh courtney is in
canton ohio hi courtney welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave how you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
i wanted to hear that um so
uh not quite sure the shortened version
of this
basically uh
i don't have much of an income right now
i'm basically my only income right now
is door dashing i am about to take
an exam to get my insurance license
to get an actual income and have an
actual job
with the limited income that i have
i've been trying to do your baby steps
for i can't tell you how long
um unfortunately it
because of another relationship that i
ended back in february was why i
couldn't really fully dave
do the baby steps
um at this point i have five dollars in
savings my question is what is the best
way to
still
work towards that end goal of at least
creating that thousand dollar
starter emergency fund with only having
about a hundred dollars a week
how come you're only making a hundred
bucks a week how many hours are you
doing doordash
uh as often as i can uh
a week what else do you do what's taking
up your time
i don't have a babysitter
so it's child care i've tried
yes i have tried numerous people and
they've all
it was either my teenage sister being a
teenage girl or the other person that i
was able to find it got better
can you find work from home right now
maybe a customer service job online
uh
studying to take my exam took up a lot
of the past couple weeks not on
insurance
yes an insurance exam is not that hard
no i um
how old are you very i don't know
25 okay all right
um here's the thing before this i had i
was trying to start like an in-home
cleaning business so i had income since
february but since then it's
it didn't
i guess i guess proved to
be as successful as i wanted it to be
what you don't need is an income you
need to allocate more hours to work
some way or another
you've got to find some way to go make
some money
because you don't have any money
you don't even have money to pay for
food
right
a hundred dollars a week we'll pay for
certainly i get assistance in that but
yeah if i didn't have that assistance i
know i wouldn't i wouldn't be able to
care what kind of assistance
um oh okay all right
well here here's the thing the reason
you don't have any money is you don't
work much
so we've got to find some way
we you have to find some way to find
some hours or some method
uh that the kid rides along with you i
don't know what it is that you go make
money
because that's your problem
there's not going to be a situation what
happened if you got like a full-time job
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
well you'd have to find a babysitter
yeah you know and what happens when you
get ready to go sell some insurance
you're gonna have to find a babysitter
so you're a single mom and you're gonna
solve that equation
and that's that's the problem you've got
there's no magic wand that makes 100 a
week work
we don't have one of those
so what this is a an income crisis kiddo
you have an income crisis
and you need to treat it that way this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage steve and dawn are with
us hey guys how are you doing hi hi dave
welcome welcome where do you guys live
northfield michigan oh cool welcome to
nashville and how much debt have you
paid off
we paid off 315 000
in seven years and five months way to go
and your range of income during that
seven years and five months it was
starting at 140 and ended around 2 30.
excellent what do you guys do for a
living
i'm a preschool teacher
i'm not i'm i'm sorry i'm an i.t okay
excellent very cool
so seven years and three hundred
thousand i'm guessing you might have
paid off your house we did you're weird
people
looking at weird people
normal people have a mortgage and a
spare bedroom for sally may not you
you're 100 debt free that's right we are
we are way to go guys all right tell us
the story what in the world happened
seven years ago they got you connected
up with this ramsey stuff
well it was it was around 2010 that i
learned about you by my friend heather
she had total money makeover and and
told me you should read this book
so i read it in like two days and told
steve about it and got him on board we
were pretty excited but you know life
kind of got in the way and
you know we had um
we only had card that at that point so
we were told by a lot of people you're
always going to have card that you know
you can't don't have to worry about
getting rid of that
but we decided that we were going to do
it and our daughter kate i remember
driving to the
credit union making the last payment
and she was like six at the time and she
said mom are we gonna call dave ramsey
and do our debt free scream
and i said well i would like to wait
until we pay our mortgage off wow
so here we are seven years later so yeah
so then a few years later we decided to
get when we bought our current house
that we were going to be really
focused and on paying the mortgage off
yeah yeah where'd it go you guys thank
you so steve were you on board
immediately you just said it like yeah
so i just got steve on board it's not
always that easy i was not on board
immediately um i had to be talked into
it much like uh a lot of things in my
life so it was a persuasive speech
okay fine i'll give it a shot absolutely
and you started doing it and you went oh
my gosh we can do this yeah it's like
carnet it just seems ridiculous now
right like why would anybody have card
you know too much
to ever go back
wow that's impressive
and uh kate did you i mean she must have
seen a lot along the journey she must
have been inspired by you guys in your
financial journey we say more is caught
than taught do you think this stuff is
stuck with her
i think so and she's actually through
her high school she's going to be taking
the foundations course her senior year
next year awesome
we're really excited about that that's
fantastic start off and so we just have
uh college next um we're hoping that
we know we're going to be able to cash
flow oh yeah wow this income and no debt
and what's the house worth yeah
um
two i'm sorry 480 i think 480 how much
you got in retirement
we have about 600 in retirement so your
baby steps millionaires we are cool
way to go guys
that happens a lot when they pay off the
house finishes
you just wake up and go oh my gosh i
guess we're millionaires look at that
yes that's awesome yeah when we got
really close at the end it was like we
were just aggressively tacking the
mortgage yeah and like paying crazy
amounts on door mark well you can see
the finish line you can sprint that's
right i mean it
you can do it even if you even if it's a
long run as long as you can see the
finish line you find out how much you
got left in the tank absolutely that's
cool well done guys very very well done
proud of you what do you tell people the
key to getting out of that is
i think it's
just
perseverance do not stop yeah and just
realizing that you know there's an end
in sight and you're going to get there
and
just i think we added on three hundred
thousand three hundred dollars onto our
mortgage payment for a while and then we
increased it to five hundred and then we
increased it to a thousand and then
pretty much we were we were paying an
extra two thousand dollars on our
mortgage bill
that's
and that curve took you on out in seven
years yeah yes you want to be your
personal best and go how much more could
you put on this month we can beat that
we can beat that'll be the pr yeah it's
awesome
still having a goal that's it
it matters it matters how does it feel
to be free
i don't think it's sunken
we're still living like we have a crazy
amount of debt
so what's the first big thing you plan
to do now that you're free
i need a new car okay much fire so i've
been driving the same car since 2008
yeah
it's got 200 000 miles on it we just
put a crazy
large
improvement on that car
so
i don't know wow gotta get a car i like
the car i like the car oh you like it
it's the coolest thing about me
oh boy it's a low bar
that's the year the iphone came the
original iphone came out of no way it's
time to upgrade
that's awesome though you know what
you're gonna get
no no dreams no idea you're still
hanging on to the old beater i love it
yeah pretty much cars are really
expensive right now oh yeah we're maybe
gonna wait just a little bit sure yeah a
way to go guys very very well done we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you since you are one that'll be
perfect and a total money makeover book
as well you can give that to somebody
and show them what to do and i won your
subscription to financial peace
university as well we'll get you the
card for that and all of those may be
things you give away or maybe some of
them you'll use yourself but either way
they're great and so we're we're proud
of you guys way to go heroes thanks
man you're weirdos not only you out of
debt house and everything but you became
baby steps how old are you became
babysits millionaires 50 years old 52.
okay that's exactly the average
millionaire it takes them seven to ten
years to pay off their house and they're
50 to 52 years old in our in our study
that's what we found you guys are
average in the best way possible you're
the typical you're the stereotypical
baby steps millionaire perfect well done
steve i'm sorry dave if i can just say
one more thing our son
cole is with us too and he's off site
right now but he has special needs and
he's 20 and
and yeah he's just been a part of this
journey as well so we just wanted to
mention him absolutely he's part of part
of the process very cool good stuff
all right stephen dawn cole and kate
from michigan 315 000 paid off house and
everything they did in the seven years
and five months making 140 to 230 that
officially puts them over the line and
their baby steps millionaires count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three
two one
[Applause]
well done well done well done
beautiful dave we got to talk about this
so paying off your house we're doing
this event tonight real estate reality
check and a big part of becoming a baby
steps millionaire and building wealth is
becoming a homeowner and paying off your
house that's a huge part of the wealth
building equation and i think people
don't always connect the dots there when
they think about wealth building
becoming a millionaire
and being a homeowner and paying off the
mortgage early not sitting around for 30
years and doing the heloc and doing all
kinds of stupid stuff and renovations
pulling money out it's about paying it
off yep yep and not about moving up
moving up moving up moving up it's about
paying it off so they bought a 300 000
house that's now worth 500
and they've got 600 in their 401ks that
puts them in a million one net worth see
your net millionaire means you have a
million dollar net worth what you own
minus what you owe assets minus
liabilities it does not mean your income
well nobody should have a million
dollars it's not a moral construct
you can discuss that if you want to
accounting definition
it's an accounting definition and so i
don't feel like i have any money it
doesn't matter it's not a feeling i
don't think it's enough doesn't matter
it's still a million it it's there's
only one definition a millionaire it's
not a feeling it's not a moral construct
it's not a it's not any of these things
it's simply assets mass liabilities it's
not your income
it's not what your broke
brother-in-law's opinion is about who
you should vote for it is none of its
wealth inequalities just unfair it's
none of that
it's none of that fair is where you get
cotton candy
and ride the tilt-a-whirl that's what
fair is don't forget the deep-fried
oreos
deep fried oil yeah you've been going to
some redneck fairs hey listen i'm fully
ingrained in the south now as a boston
deep fried oreo try it sometime it'll
change your life my mouth's watering
what do you mean it'll change your body
kind of restrict it i i i did thinking
about it
it's awful we'll go to the fair together
dave deep fried i've done deep fried
moon pies i've made them wow i've never
done
that's a thing i didn't know well of
course you go to a sphere you could get
deep-fried anything deep fry anything in
the south you know that that's true
that's true well
i don't know what that has to do with
being a millionaire but there we have it
trailed hard there yeah hard left this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today welcome to the ramsey show
common sense for your dollars and cents
and for your life
open phones at
825-5225 marquita is in seattle hey
marquita how are you
greetings gentlemen
greetings how may we help
i am calling because i need some advice
papa dave okay my grandfather
was a longshoreman
he bought property
two lots in california
and two lots in mississippi
when he passed away he um passed the
lots
um
he gave the lots to his 10 his 10
children
out of the 10 children four have passed
away
three of three of the four that have
died have
heirs
six are still alive
two that are currently alive had their
health is deteriorating
one had a recent stroke
and my mother
is dealing with als
and so
my question is
what is the process and the cost
selling sibling estate interest
for income just so that
um
my mom who's dealing with this illness
can have some sort of income
to live on
um
any
among this huge number of heirs
there's no communication and this is
what's prompted me to call you because
it's always been
circling in the back of my head
subconsciously because no one's talked
about it and now that they're getting
older the 10 siblings are in their late
70s early 80s they're passing away but
no one is i don't i haven't heard any
conversations about
um
heirs inheriting their parents interests
that have passed away that's what will
happen so my cons
right and so that has happened however
no conversation has been tabled and so
that my now that my mother is dealing
with als
um you're getting ready to be the owner
of my mind yeah you're you're getting
ready to be the owner of this and she
could use the cash right now yeah
correct and i wanted to know what is the
process and the cost
do i um for selling her and not pardon
me if i'm not using the correct verbiage
is it the estate interest i don't know
if it's just her percentage sibling
she's got a hand she's got a basket full
of partners
and she's just selling her her portion
of ownership
to someone
uh preferably the most likely would be
uh another
another relative of some kind
you know so what i do start calling all
the different relatives to say is
anybody interested in mom's portion
and then you would say okay her portion
is was it one-tenth is that what it was
i don't know what the uh i don't know
what this is it should still be a tenth
whatever her original percentage is
still is you said there was ten kids yes
one chance of 10 siblings yeah okay so
if we say the lots are worth a million
dollars as a group then her one-tenth is
worth a hundred thousand and you know
we'd be willing to sell that right now
for sixty five thousand dollars
discount it got it and then if somebody
wants to buy out her tenth
um and
maybe somebody in that pile of
siblings more likely uh kids of the
siblings nieces and nephews
uh might want to be trying to kind of
gather up ownership because if someone
can gather up 51 of the ownership they
can act on behalf of everyone else
because they have controlling interest
51 which is a little over half yeah i
mean you can force a sale at that point
you can force the others to sell it
which is really what should have
happened that should have happened
decades ago
right they should have put these
properties up for sale and divvyed up
the cash
because cash go always divvy
right
yeah is there any formal agreement that
you have
there is no formal agreement i checked
with my mother and she said and i asked
her to verify is she
listed on the property has she seen the
deed with her name on it does she recall
she has a percentage or or is it joint
ownership does she remember any of the
verbiage and she could not recall but
she did say her name was listed all 10
siblings were listed on there so i don't
know do we need a real estate attorney
or an attorney
not until you have a buyer a profit
got it and the only buyer likely
nobody really wants this
i wouldn't want it for any price i
wouldn't give you two dollars for it
because i don't want to deal with this
basket of crazy okay
um
but the uh but one of the one of the
people in the basket may want it that's
your most likely buyer
by far okay so i just start contacting
them you have any semblance of any guess
of what these lots are worth
uh two of the lots are in a historic
black town which is the first black town
in in allensworth california which is uh
about two and a half hours away from uh
south south i don't need all that what
are they worth
i don't know okay that's all i'm asking
i mean because if you if you're dealing
with one tenth of a hundred thousand
dollars
i'm not even gonna fool with it
if you're dealing with one tenth of a
million dollars then maybe it's worth
fooling with
makes sense you know i wouldn't spend
twelve thousand dollars in legal fees
chasing ten grand yeah
so you know i try to get some guess of
what they're worth and try to have
some contact with some of the uh
more intelligent more business-minded
uh
nieces and nephews and or siblings but
probably nieces or nephews and then
start trying to talk one of them into
buying up controlling interest in these
things so they can flip them and get the
mess cleaned up because the likelihood
of getting all of these people to line
up and sign a deed together and sell the
thing to somebody else as an individual
it's an act of congress right there well
we're trying to get two people disagree
that ain't even talked
i mean i mean to agree to do something
and not only to agree to sell it but
also to agree on the price oh my god
what is the right way to do this dave if
you were the grandfather leaving this to
ten kids is there a simple
i would have just settled it
requires it's auctioned or so sold or
auctioned within 12 months of my death
and then that money's divvied up among
the kids because 10 people owning a
piece of real estate is unwieldy as we
just discovered okay it's just it's
unwieldy now our case our real estate is
left into a trust and the trust sets up
all the agreement for how things are
operated and then the kids
are the beneficiaries of the trust and
it's been clearly communicated everybody
knows this there's a full plan out on
how it will function and so forth and
then you know the kids they have voting
rights in the trust and if two of the
three ramsey kids decided to sell it all
they could sell it all and divvy it up
majority they want to hold it they can
hold it but they've got a process for
governance and communication and a
process to decide whether to keep a
certain piece of property within that
trust or not those kinds of things
that's one way you can do it but just
dumping a whole bunch of people onto a
deed
with no no mechanisms for governance uh
is well it creates a mess you know what
we've got here is we turned a piece of
property the value of it into zero
potentially
and then it split because of the errors
and now it gets way more complicated
exactly
wow exactly so yeah you do want this
this is one reason we talk about mama
bear legal forms have a will
uh uh you know get cat with somebody get
your will in place and if you've got
substantial assets leave them into a
trust
but in that guy's case he might have
just needed a will and the will could
have simply stated grandpa the original
grandpa in the story you know upon my
death these lots are to be liquidated
and turned into cash by slow sale or
auction within 12 months of my death and
you can just say that in the will and
then whatever they bring the kids divvy
it up and by the way if one of the kids
wants to buy it they can
yep so there you go nice and
we actually have a few pieces of real
estate that are not left in the trust
and one of the things we did that just
for fun just to tell people because uh
if one of if uh
somebody wants to sell
a piece of real estate
uh or buy it uh if if
the other person wants to keep it they
can buy out the other shares at 80
of their share at a slight discount well
because you're not going to net 100
after real estate fees and closing costs
anyway
and so you have it appraised and at 80
cents on the dollar the other the other
siblings can buy out the other one if
you the deal has to make sense so it's
already set up though it's not a
negotiation
it's set up if you want to buy it this
is the price it avoids conflict that's
for sure lots of communication lots of
clarity
lots of yeah that's why i told her sixty
five thousand on a hundred thousand
there just doesn't
get rid of it yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us america open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two
will william is in tampa to start off
this hour hey william what's up
hey dave and george how are you guys
great man how can we help
um me and my wife are flipping a
investment property
and we are in contract and come to find
out the people purchasing the house are
in an extended stay
and they're paying them 3 500.
now i had the bright idea to let them
move in before they close and my wife
instantly said no
so we're not doing it philosophically i
know she's right but can you tell me
logically
why she's right
um
well she's not necessarily right
uh it's done all the time
that people move into properties uh or
to remain in properties after they sell
them
either one
um
you know but what you would have to do
is you would have to have a series of
check boxes that that made it wise okay
one is i'd want to be very sure of their
financing
okay that they're are they financing the
property that they're purchasing
yes okay
i want a lot of details about that and
know that they're
qualified their mortgage company needs
to give me a lot of assurances this deal
is closing
okay
two is i want a ridiculous deposit
okay that is refunded upon closing
like i don't know what's the property
selling for
315
okay like 10 000 15 000 bucks
that's what i'd call a ridiculous
deposit
okay but they get it back as long as
they close
right
yes uh then the next thing is is
obviously well not obviously but the the
other thing is there's a lease
a written agreement
that if they don't close by a certain
date they move out and they forfeit
their deposit
okay would you do a weekly lease or a
monthly lease well it would be it just
be a written document that gives the
terms of the lease which is how much
they're paying you how much the deposit
is and that that if they don't close by
x date they move out and forfeit their
deposit
okay
okay now if you've got a solid document
like that you've got a big but deposit
like that and you've got real real good
assurance on these people are studs as
far as their finances go their financing
is going uh then there's not much risk
to this you kind of almost hope they
don't close and you pocket 15 grand
okay
that makes sense
well
it does that's why i i wanted to do it
but when she doesn't want to do
something i i listen to that well i
listen to it too just just letting them
move in she's right i wouldn't do that
with no without those other three things
okay
but if they don't want to put up a
deposit good sit sit in the extended k
they don't want to sign a lease good sit
in the extended
uh stay i call extinct care
this is daycare
but the uh
um or if their finances look iffy then
yeah that would be she would be right in
any of those if you don't do at least
those three things okay i'll flip it on
its head i just did this only it was me
okay or something similar i sold my home
which was a multi-million dollar
property
and the buyer part of the agreement was
i did it last year part of the agreement
was i got to stay there rent free
for four months after i closed on it
but i i left them a big deposit
and we had a written agreement and then
we moved out and we got our deposit back
simple deal right but part of the
agreement was i stayed in a house that
they owned because we closed it and i
stayed in my old house four months after
closing
i mean you see what i'm doing
so that's a similar deal but it's a
seller deal rather than a buyer deal but
still that that's the process so the
whole thing george's is covering the
basis cut
dot your eyes cross your teeth
you know now are you doing that with any
of your sales are you moving yeah so the
the buyers of our current home are
allowing us to live there 10 days after
closing for free as part of the deal
yeah and so that's part of it and it's
all in the agreements and that it all
makes sense and if we don't close
there's ramifications and so you know
all of that makes sense when you have
your your eyes dotted your teeth crossed
but when you just do it willy-nilly
without any agreements on the table
that's what you're getting his wife
would be right yeah and so those people
do that they just oh yeah whatever you
know and then you get into a problem
yeah you know so just make sure you do
your due diligence you've got the right
paperwork in place you've got the
agreements you feel good about the
closing parker's in atlanta hey parker
how are you
i am good how are you better than we
deserve what's up i understand so
my wife and i just accepted new jobs
a few weeks ago
and just so happens we ended up starting
at almost the exact same time cool so
with that comes of course open
enrollment for health care things of
that nature
and that got me wondering do you have
any thoughts or opinions
on each of us having a family health
care plan
where one of them would be like a ppo or
something generic
and the other one is an hsa that we
would attempt not to touch you can't do
it
you're going to screw up everything okay
if you have two health plans covering
the same
people
they argue about who is primary
and neither one of them will pay
so just buy it buy a health plan for
your family at one place or the other
okay so i should not do dual at all
you no dual dual dual gives you
absolutely zero benefit they are not
gonna both pay
okay they're going to argue about who
paige
okay how many people in the family
parker
it's just my wife and i oh okay
so
does your company furnish yours free and
hers furnished hurts free
um i mean we pay into it if that's what
you're asking no that's not no that's
not free if you're paying into it no
okay right so you both have to pay for
it okay
uh are you paying for yours more than
you would pay extra to be on hers
no
or vice versa
because it might be cheaper for both of
you to be on one or the other
as an add-on than it is to have two
standalone policies
but it might be cheaper if the companies
are subsidizing it for both of you to
each have your own at your own companies
it'll be fine but there's no reason for
any kind of dual double coverage because
you don't benefit from it they pay for
it you don't get anything except a
hassle oh yeah my wife works here at
ramsey and we both have separate
policies because it makes more sense
it's more it's mathematically better
because you've got to do the family plan
if not and we don't have kids there's
not you know there's oh and that doesn't
save you any money because we pay for a
bunch of yours okay so we got to crunch
the numbers here and go what makes sense
for us based on health and cost that's
it that makes sense okay good this is
the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at eight eight
two five five two two five
guys we get it when you're worried
money is all-consuming
you can wonder if you've got enough to
pay your bills or even afford to fill up
at the gas station it's always on your
mind
but you work too hard to live like that
you shouldn't have to be stressed out
you should have peace and when you have
a proven detailed plan that millions of
people have used to not only get out of
debt but to become millionaires
well it gives you a lot of peace that's
why we named it financial peace
university
almost 10 million families people have
gone through this class now
to learn how to budget to save to spend
to invest
become debt free to be outrageously
generous
and now is a great time to take the
course we just updated all of almost
every single video
and includes george campbell dr john
deloney now and you don't want to miss
it so it's rachel cruz dave ramsey dr
john deloney george campbell and uh it's
quite a lineup you're going to love the
new lessons
decide today that you're done letting
money stress rule your life you can do
this get started with financial peace
university by visiting
ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash fpu our question of the day comes
from blinds.com
find out for yourself why they're the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings with free samples free
shipping and new promos every month
you'll save even more always use the
promo code ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from sean in
mississippi he says my wife and i have
been tackling our two hundred thousand
dollars of debt for the past three years
and we have about 55k left
we've continued to tithe and contribute
to various christian organizations this
has caused some debate between us
i'm more aligned with taking a step back
from tithing and paying off our debt
however my wife remains steadfast in our
need to continue to tithe at least ten
percent of our income i know the baby
steps say that we need to complete baby
step two before starting baby step seven
however our charitable contributions are
very important to us if we had not
donated over the past three years we
would be debt-free now do you have any
recommendations on how to persuade my
wife to concentrate solely on paying
down debt
wow
well that's assuming that we agree with
you sean isn't it
that's a problem yeah i think we're the
problem is we're probably not going to
agree with either one of you here
yeah sean is looking at the math and
going well if we stop tithing we could
pay off debt faster doesn't that make
sense dave that's the whole point of the
process
but it's not there's a heavy spiritual
component if you're a person of faith
that you should tithe 10 and that's the
baseline yeah and scripture is pretty
clear that it's first fruits
the tithe the 10 to your local church is
first fruits it comes off the top before
you do anything else now uh we're not
legalistic about it that's just what the
bible says
and so if you want to do something else
god's not going to be mad at you but his
instruction manual is very clear
that a tenth of your income goes to your
local church
this is what evangelicals have taught
and believed for years now lots of
people
have different you know viewpoints or
whatever within different denominational
movements but evangelicals
across the board this is what we teach
what we believe and there's a lot of
scriptural basis for it obviously and so
uh but again nothing has to do with your
salvation
god doesn't need your money the church
that he really needs your money if they
do they got other issues but real really
this is about you having a rhythm of
giving in your life and that god wants
you to have giving at the top of your
list always
so now where i would disagree with your
wife
is the other things that are not a tenth
of your income going to your local
church are not tithing the extra to
those
offerings
those are called offerings
and there is no scriptural indication
that offerings come from anything but
surplus and while you have debt you
don't have surplus
so offering should come from surplus so
i personally
did and would recommend that while
you're getting out of debt you tithe and
nothing more
and so i did not give to any other
ministries any other para church
organizations or anything else while i
was getting out of debt except my local
church my tenth you'll have plenty of
time to do that later once you're out of
debt but you're taking care of your own
household first you don't have surplus
and offerings come
from
surplus
and so even extra things that the church
is asking for we're in a building
program we're trying to
raise money for
uh
whatever cause that the church is doing
well that they're going to take it out
of my tithe check
um and that's what i did while i was
doing it again none of this though is a
salvation issue none of this makes god
love you more or less
none of this falls in that bucket but
these are just the what if you do a
detailed in-depth bible study this is
where it will lead you and that's why
it's what we've done and what we've told
you to do now where would you say to
bring those back in the offerings the
charitable contributions would that come
after baby step three yes because we're
kind of done with the gazelle intensity
we're moving to intentional because baby
step three as far as i'm concerned is
taking care of your own household if you
don't have an emergency fund and you're
not debt-free you haven't taken care of
your rocky foundation and your scripture
says take care of your own household
first
or you're worse than an unbeliever okay
so take care of your own household first
and that doesn't mean be selfish as a
course of your life or as a character
quality it just means that you've gotta
you know you gotta feed your kids before
you feed hungry kids because yours are
hungry too okay and so that that's all
that means you pay your light bill
before you pay the light bill at the
homeless shelter
and so you can let that fuel you i mean
if you're on the debt-free journey
absolutely it should fuel you they're
passionate you have a desire about
giving it means you're going to pro
there's a high correlation between that
and people who build wealth let's get
out of that faster so that we can do
what we really want to do exactly which
is give out rages and the most fun
you'll ever have with money we teach on
generosity a lot we believe in
generosity
but uh but that that's the nuanced
detail of how to flesh out your
generosity so your wife is trying to do
too much you all have been doing too
much and you're trying to do too little
so you both are wrong but the difference
according to what we teach and according
what i believe so there we go
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five carla is in las
vegas hey carla how are you
i'm good dude uh hi george hey
how can we help
so
i have a question um
we have a
home we have we have our house that we
paid off
um and we are currently in the process
of purchasing a new home great
yeah so we my husband and i
um initially thought about putting the
house for sale
using the funds from that home from our
current home into the new home
but
we're kind of
unsure if we should do that
or just keep it as a
rental property you have the money to
pay for the new home in cash if you
don't sell yours
no
we don't
um
i'd probably sell it then
i'm gonna sell and use the proceeds on
the new one what's the new one gonna
cost
so the new one is right under six
hundred thousand
and what's the mortgage you need to take
out on that
um
anywhere from three to thirty four
hundred a month
but are you taking out all six hundred
and you have a down payment on this new
one because all your money's tied up in
the old house
right so we do have savings and um we
are putting
i mean
the the minimum that we should put is
about
50.
okay no here's the thing i would not do
this i just wouldn't do it you need to
sell your current house here's why okay
let's say
that you you keep the current house it's
paid for and you have a debt on your
home
effectively it wasn't directly but
effectively it's the same thing as
having borrowed on a paid for home to
buy a rental property
and we would never tell you to do that
but you see how that's exactly what
you've ended up doing
yeah
yeah so you're going to take this money
and any money you got in savings and
you're going to either pay cash for or
almost pay cash for the new property get
it paid off and then you should start
saving in cash to buy your next rental
in cash but i'm not going to lead you to
borrow money on your residence to go buy
rentals and effectively that's what's
happening here you're not quite at a
place to be a real estate investor yeah
you need to get rid of it and i know it
sounds fancy or it sounds sophisticated
and i've only made rental property yeah
that's great but you don't do it this
way this is this is you're gonna get
yourself in a crack here kiddo don't do
it don't do it get in your residence get
your residents paid off and then start
saving up and buying rentals with cash
it's what i did years ago and i've got
several hundred million dollars worth of
real estate this is the ramsey show
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org
budget don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage paul
and stephanie are with us hey guys how
are you
hello we're good thank you welcome
welcome where do you live
we are from lynchburg virginia oh fun
liberty town yeah that's right good
stuff did you go to liberty yes i went
there for grad school and then he went
there for about a year ah excellent okay
cool so how much debt have you paid off
one hundred thousand eight hundred and
eighty seven dollars and ninety five
cents love it how long did that take 29
months whoa and your range of income
during that time started around 53 000
up to about 95 000. cool what do y'all
do for a living i'm a physical therapist
assistant
and i'm a marriage and family therapist
excellent so what was the 101 000
all student loans all student loans and
did it in 29 months how long y'all been
married
just over three years okay so right
after the honeymoon basically you sat
down and said okay this is a problem
tell me the story what happened yeah so
it started more so in 2017. we had you
come to our church and did the whole
cutting up of credit cards
and offered after that our church
offered financial peace and so we ended
up taking thomas road yeah with jonathan
okay yeah all right cool yeah so uh and
we had never heard of you before that
and so we ended up taking the class with
our life group um honestly like really
enjoyed it but still at the time felt
like we didn't have any money to save or
like college students yeah yeah so we
waited a couple years
got married we got married two weeks
after i graduated from grad school and
then the six months later was when our
my
tuition
payments started
and so
at the time i had started calculating
how much it would cost to
if we did like the 10-year plan that
they automatically put you on and it was
going to be 20 000 extra dollars
and i told paul that and we were just
like no
that's just like wasted money it felt
like you didn't want to make a donation
to sallie mae no no no we didn't yeah
when steph said that it was pretty much
game on uh
then you remember that guy that was at
church that time yeah yes that's right
because then we got back into he i don't
remember this but he said that i just
like started youtubing you and was
looking up a bunch of videos and then
got back into uh we started listening to
podcasts and like honestly from there um
we've just been like doing your plan
since wow so good for you it's awesome
yeah very cool so basically right after
you got married all this stuff comes
loose because you graduate yeah
everything starts coming due where
there's twenty thousand dollar
discussion yeah youtube pops up and you
go okay we're getting out of this yeah
absolutely pretty much yeah good for you
we just yeah we just didn't we didn't
want to do it anymore because he was
still in school when i finished so we
got to like thankfully start with mine
and then he started a little bit later
so as a newlywed couple you kind of want
to do all the things and upgrade the
cars and we graduated and get the house
what were the sacrifices you guys had to
make in the face of probably all of your
friends doing those things
yeah um
i'll start we kind of loved that process
just because we honestly like have not
really i don't know we haven't really
spent our lives just like getting
expensive things and so we always tell
everyone our apartment you can vacuum
the whole thing from one outlet and so
it's like super local there's a park
it's a long coaster a small apartment
you should be a real estate agent you're
in the wrong field right it's so small
um so we just had really low expenses
overall like we we had you know low cost
of living um super cars that's right
yeah super low um
phone payments
um the laundry oh yeah we were um
we had to use quarters at the laundromat
we decided we weren't going to dry our
clothes we were just going to hang them
up in front of a fan and save the dollar
50 and wow
like a little house on the prairie
pretty much everything we did
[Laughter]
you know you know you're going to wait a
couple days until you need that shirt or
that pair it's perfect that is some
sacrifice impressive to save a dollar
fifty but that added up it did
yeah 101 09 that's that's legit i mean
you kicked it you kicked it hard so now
at the end of the day what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
because you're professionals you've done
it
um i think a big part of it was getting
on the same page and like with
sacrificing try to find um some fun
things to do along with it we did a lot
of hiking like things for free um even
like with our laundry or not turning the
heat on all winter we just found ways to
save money like wherever we could and it
felt like you're probably like you came
out of it didn't you you did oh yeah it
was so fun yeah
the dollar fifty really didn't matter it
was just part of the game yeah it was
just that i think it's just the attitude
of saving like brought us closer
together in our marriage and then just
it gave us a very real goal um it helped
for us to like set dates and try to hit
those which also makes it super sweet
when you pay that last payment oh yeah
yeah and even we had setbacks we had
like a yeah eight thousand dollar tax
bill because we we didn't know she was a
private contractor and so we were
working through that and
setbacks just staying the course and
chipping away a little bit at a time
what was it like using a dryer for the
first time
it's magic
we haven't done it yet oh my goodness
oh wow we go over to our friend's house
and it's pretty magical
that's amazing
i thought i was frugal dave this is
impressive they go to their friend's
house that's not even a dollar fifty you
know so that's great that's true
guys that's awesome very very cool we're
very proud of you congratulations
who were your biggest cheerleaders
i would say our families have been super
big encouragers throughout it and then
we've had friends along the way um
specifically friends who we think like
have been just wiser with their money
and so especially with like the
different setbacks that we've had we've
been able to just ask them and say hey
what do you think we should do in this
situation and without them we probably
would have you know had bigger setbacks
so i think that was the biggest thing
yeah i think family in our corner was
always supporting us and then we just
had good people around us that were
uh point us to good tax accountants
figuring out her taxes and just good
ways to save and good ways to handle our
money yeah very good well
congratulations you guys very well done
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires our latest number one best
seller for you uh how ordinary people
build extraordinary wealth how you can
too that's your next step
that's your next process you go ahead
and think good next big milestone anyway
becoming a baby steps millionaire we've
also got a copy of total money makeover
for you to give to somebody that was
encouraged by your story probably and if
you haven't been through financial peace
university officially and now you can do
it we're going to give you a one-year
membership to that or you can give it
away whatever you want to do so well
done you guys we're very very proud of
you all right paul and stephanie
lynchburg virginia 101 000 paid off in
29 months making 53-95
count it down and let's talk let's hear
a debt-free scream
all right three two
one
[Applause]
that is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
that's how it's done hang in the clothes
to dry love it tyler's in orlando hey
tyler welcome to the ramsay show
hey i've always wanted to ask this how
you doing sir better than i deserve
what's up
uh not much so i um
i i'm in a position where i'm gonna be
getting a promotion soon where i'll be
uh
i'll be making 200 000 a year um and
currently making 80 000. wow that's
awesome big jump
yeah
the thing is though is that i come from
a
humble mechanic background making 30 to
40 000 a year this is unfathomable
amount of money to me i i don't want to
go stupid with it i want to do good with
it and i just wanted some some advice
i've i've listened to you for the past
year or so i kind of have a little bit
of an idea but like i said with these
kind of extra zeros at the end i'm kind
of you know a little a little scared a
little anxious and a little lost so
well congratulations man i know it's
scary but it sounds like you want to do
the right thing here do you have any
debt
uh i have about 20 000 uh in debt
between the truck and just some other
little things uh you know nicer
basically places struck a
computer and stuff like that okay um but
that that i i did plan on my first
paycheck that i get from the
company in october just going ahead and
paying it off how much you have in
savings just
uh zero dollars and zero cents at the
moment um
well that'll all change very soon i'm
going to put you on a plan here because
we're running into the break but i'm
going to get you financial peace
university i want you to watch all nine
video lessons and with that you're going
to get every dollar to start budgeting
and paying attention to where every
single cent of this 200 000 is going
we're going to get you an emergency fund
we're going to pay off the debt we're
going to get you investing and you're
going to put this 200 000 to work my
friend so hang on the line austin will
pick up we will hook you up with
financial peace university
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personalities my
co-host today i'm dave ramsey this is
the ramsey show open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five
dan is with us in boston hey dan welcome
to the ramsay show
how you doing great man what's up
i just have a quick question for you
because i i listen to your show quite a
bit um first i want to say thank you for
taking my call and i wanted to like a
lot of the stuff is structured around
houses so i know you would say do the
15-year fixed and it should be the
mortgage should be no more than 25
percent of your take home
if you wanted to get like let's say you
wanted to get a two unit
instead of a house you know i don't have
kids or anything like that would you
would the same thing apply and then how
would you factor in the rents that you
get okay you know what i mean if that
makes sense yeah yeah i think the the
way to answer the question for you
for you to answer the question is this
why
i'm asking you why do we
tell you to save to not have a house
payment more than 25 percent of your
take on pay
so you're not biting off more than you
can chew basically
right and so you can get the house paid
off
yeah okay
now
the duplex changes that because you have
a renter
you have repairs
and you have rental income
right
yeah okay so what would keep you from
uh you know
what what percentage
would keep you from uh
biting off more than you could chew and
not being able to get the house paid off
like sooner
yeah i mean like you said i like i like
your i like your
i mean you could use the 25 but my point
is if you okay we're gonna use that rent
as
i'm not counting it at a hundred percent
like it's not there like it's always
coming because rent doesn't always come
absolutely but if i wanted to raise the
25 up a little bit by
you know let's say that the unit is
renting for the other units written for
a thousand bucks okay
if i wanted to say all right i'm gonna
take
three to five hundred of that and add it
to the 25
that might still meet the common sense
guideline that we're giving you does
that make sense
that makes absolute sense i figured
you'd either say that or
have a bigger instead of three to six
months do like
you know
12 to 18 just to no
i'm still gonna stick there yeah i'd
still stick with the three to six months
now the other thing you got to know is
you you do need in your property account
you in addition to your three to six
months you need some money there
anytime you have rental property crap
breaks
yeah and they break stuff if it doesn't
break on its own
so absolutely yeah you just
you're going to be surprised at what
your expenses are on these things it's
not it's not all
uh
skittles and rainbows and let me remind
you you live next to your renter so they
will be knocking they will see you
outside and they will complain about
things so there's uh you got to think
about that too when you're looking at
duplexes yeah and what tritter you're
putting in you know so the great news is
you live next to your renter you can see
them and get in touch with them the bad
news is you live next year renter so vet
them very well so yeah that's that's
going to be the thing
francis is with us in salt lake city hi
francis how are you
dave and george what a privilege thank
you so much for taking my call i've been
listening
to you dave since i was a teenager my
father turned me on to you my mom and
dad and what a privilege thank you so
much and bless you god bless you how can
we help
thank you
i so breach brief overview i'm 55
single mom i've raised two kids
of
i've been through two bouts of breast
cancer
but i have fabulous news as of three
years ago i'm 100 debt free
yay i know i need i haven't celebrated
that with anybody so thank you
i guess my heart is still heavy because
i am debt free but i owe nothing i i
don't i don't own a home i've rented
this entire time
so
i just quick overview on my on my income
and my bills i make 22 dollars an hour
i'm an admin assistant here in salt lake
um i get paid every two weeks
my checks are 15.60
but my take home is only 8.50 and this
is why
i
have been diligent in putting 15 percent
into my
401k
which is
of
460 a month and i get a four percent
match for my employer
and i do my hsa max which is 300 a month
and as of today there's four thousand
dollars in there
and
uh what's your question what's your
question for answers my question is
i have two i have two questions dave
i have ten thousand dollars in an
emergency fund
and
that is it
for savings i i have i work part-time
francis what's your question
my question is do i use my few extra
dollars i have a month with my side job
to save for a home yes
and i might even back off on the hsa and
some of the retirement savings
temporarily and get you a down payment
saved up for a house
is that not what you wanted to hear
i know you're going to be honest with me
i guess i just
i had 20 grand in there and i started
getting the you're never going to have
20 percent down with the how a starter
house is four and five hundred thousand
dollars now francis you're not gonna
ever make that at your age now you'll be
buying a house at 70.
so i thought okay
starter house is not four or five
hundred thousand that's a meaty that's
the median house price in america right
now is 380 and that would be very true
in salt lake city a starter house is 150
to 200 000 and you don't have to have
the 20 down on your first purchase
you're just going to have pmi if you
don't have 20 percent down but you need
to get in the real estate game because
you do not want to live to 85 and for
the next 30 years pay increasing rents
every year
because rents are going to go up every
year they have as long as i've been
alive
they go up every year
rent doesn't go down
and it does and it doesn't stabilize and
it doesn't level off
and so you want to get rent out of your
life because it's a destabilizer to your
golden years
so yeah it's time to do that and it
might mean getting some more income in
the door if you might want to look for a
new job you might want to take on extra
work right now in order to get that down
payment yeah and it's okay to slow down
or stop your retirement and certainly
your hsa
uh savings for a short period of time
two years three years here and you buy a
home when you're 58.
and it creates a fixed expense you know
and you get a good a cute little starter
it can even be a little condo but let's
get our foot in the door on this real
estate thing so it doesn't
uh it doesn't continue to escalate and
get out of reach for you permanently
but yeah you're going to get there and
and yeah george is right you may want to
relook this career you're not making a
ton of money
um you're doing okay you're not starving
to death and you're very diligent you're
very careful and smart but that's that's
what i would do if i were in your shoes
going into retirement it's important to
not only own a home but get one paid off
because it stabilizes the largest part
of your budget
and it changes what kind of retirement
you have
you don't have a mortgage hanging over
your head or any other kind of debt or
rent yeah well francis tune in tonight
for our real estate reality check event
i think it'll be encouraging for you to
hear you know what's going on in the
market the right way to buy a house how
to do it with wisdom i hope it's
encouraging to you and that's at 7 pm
central tonight yeah just jump on
ramseysolutions.com for those of you
listening to this this is
july the 14th on thursday night we'll be
doing this event the real estate reality
check there's a lot of people facing a
lot of stuff out there emotionally
regarding uh whether they think a real
estate is going to crash
or whether they're going to be priced
out of the market for the rest of their
lives or whatever and there's some real
things to talk about on this and to get
things done so
let's um you guys join us tonight it's
completely free by the way the live
stream tonight and it'll be from 7
central to about 8 central give or take
and so jump in and join us open phones
at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that was a good hour
george campbell good times a lot of
housing calls which not shocking but we
didn't really plan for that with this
real estate event tonight but it's on
top of mine for a lot of people it's a
it's a it's what a lot of people are
talking about
uh austin ben zach andrew james and
kelly in the booth great job in there
guys uh that does put this particular
hour of the ramsey show in the books
hang on we'll be with you before you
know it
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual real amazing
relationships george campbell ramsey
personality host of the fine print on
ramsey networks a podcast exposing
what the fine print taketh away
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five starting off this hour
is david and charlotte hi david welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave so great to talk to you um
appreciate you taking my call
so
i'm 53 and me and my wife have been
following your philosophy for many years
we are through all the baby steps we
have our house paid off just out about
two years ago
and we actually have another house a
rental house that's totally paid for
um
great so we also yeah it's great we
are very blessed and i have a great
business that i love
um here's my question um
you know we have
iras and roth iras
you know i say we've been following your
philosophy but the only thing
that i can't seem to do is keep money
in the stock market
i have made many mistakes pulling it out
putting it back in
and you know we've it's cost us a lot of
money
if i would have just kept it in there we
would have been you know we would have
quite a bit more in our iras
now my question is like do i really you
know mentally it's just a problem for me
to keep it in there it's been i want to
watch it every day multiple times
looking at it
question is do i really need to have
money in the stock market at this point
no i mean you could just buy real estate
if you want to do that and do whatever
you want to do there's no there's no uh
mandate that you do this
but well i would challenge and i would
challenge you david that i think what
you do need to do
is you do need to learn how to um
analyze and assess and learn about an
investment
and then may be able to make a choice to
do that investment or not do that
investment
okay so you bought this rental property
right
yes
do you fret about it
no why we don't
because
it's not something that can go up and
down every day yes it is
well you're right um
i guess it's just it's just different
for me it's a tangible thing i can see
it
um i get a rent check every month
um
but you also said a minute ago you also
said a minute ago that if you'd left the
money in the market you would have a lot
more now
that's true okay
so here's the thing
it's always interesting to me the the
biggest difference in real estate
uh
in actual fact is that it is tangible
that you can walk over there and touch
the bricks and mortar
and you know
see if there's weeds in the yard or
whatever right that kind of thing
um and that does give us an emotional
comfort that is a reasonable
observation okay
but what real estate does not do that's
different than stock is there is zero
guarantees
the only reason that we become
emotionally comfortable with real estate
is because we are more intimately
familiar
with its history with its track record
because we grew up with it we grew up in
that neighborhood we've been around that
neighborhood 20 years whatever and you
just kind of go well houses in that
neighborhood go up and even if there was
a bump in the road and went down a
little bit i'm not going to panic
because generally houses in that
neighborhood have been are worth a lot
more than they were 20 years ago and i'm
just even though that might have been a
weekly or a monthly thing or even a
annual thing
where it was a little soft or a little
bad
no need to panic because i'm good with
the long-term track record right
i would challenge you that
you should be able to do the same thing
with the stock market
now if you don't want to i'm not going
to be mad at you but this is an
intellectual exercise in other words
learning something new that you don't
know today because if you could
internalize
the historical data on the stock market
by sitting with a smart vista pro and
learning and looking at this i've got
one mutual fund that's 80 something
years old it's only had like 10 or 15
down years out of 80 years it's got a
12.2 average annual return for 80 years
that's more safe than your rental house
right statistically mathematically
right but you got to get that down in
your heart
so you quit looking at the freaking
charts every day
i don't look at my mutual funds any more
often than i look at my real estate
so i'm not i'm not trying to say you're
stupid for not doing this if you can't
get comfortable stop doing it okay but i
think as a part of your personal growth
plan
you
demanding of yourself that you learn
something new
would be you just need to study this
market a little bit this market the
stock market thing a little bit more so
if you want to pull it out and say i'm
not going in for three more years but i
am going to meet with my
smart vista pro
who has the heart of a teacher and i'm
going to get comfortable
because of knowledge
uh my people perish for lack of
knowledge the bible says
so it's just knowledge gives you
calmness yeah on top of the perspective
of looking back at the stock market for
40 years and going oh the s p 500 some
serious appreciation there with just a
few dips i feel good about this over the
long term so we talk about how the only
people that get hurt on the roller
coaster are the ones who jump off early
and you jumped off early a whole bunch
of times and that hurt and you don't
want to go back on that roller coaster
but like dave's saying if you meet with
a smart investor pro and they outline
all this for you you're gonna go
okay i feel good about getting that roth
ira back up and going investing in good
growth stock mutual funds diversified
across four types we're not talking
about single stocks that are super
volatile i agree don't do that but if
you're talking about the stock market in
general
it's a safe bet over the long term yeah
so you know here's the thing david if
you are 100 gonna jump in and out of it
stop doing it because you're gonna lose
money
okay
just stop stop and go on and do
something else
you know and go buy some real estate and
there but i i just when i bump into
something like that there's two kinds of
fear that we all have me included
i have fear
of things that i should be afraid of i
don't need to touch a hot stove i don't
need to stand in the middle of the
interstate with 18 wheelers coming by
okay that's a that's a good fear it
saves your life
because the data that around that fear
is
that you know if you're not afraid
you're going to get killed okay or
burned or whatever right so but the
other kind of fear is false evidence
appearing real f-e-a-r okay
and that is i just don't know yet it's
like the first time i i'll never forget
i've told this story on there 100 times
my dad gives me the keys to the car that
was dumber than a rock i was 12 years
old so move the car around back well it
was a long time ago we gravel driveway
so i got in the car 12 years old started
the car
and stepped on the accelerator all the
way the floor oh boy i just about dug a
ditch in the driveway with those back
tires spinning on that gravel driveway
because i mean i did what i was doing
and you know when you first learn to
drive you're freaking out because you
don't know what you're doing
but now you drive with your knees and
people put on their makeup and eat and
do calculations and check their twitter
account while they're driving dave i
think you still drive like that 12 year
old you're burning rubber i've seen you
well that boy lives inside of me i can
tell you that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today let me ask you a question
when you think of a millionaire
what kind of job do you picture them
having is it some kind of high-powered
executive position like a vp or ceo
well here's the thing only 15 of
millionaires actually have jobs
that are
in management
positions
the reality is the top five careers for
millionaires in america are engineer
number one accountant number two teacher
number three manager like we said number
four an attorney is number five
that's just one of the surprising things
our team found when we conducted the
largest study of millionaires ever done
we talked over 10 000 millionaires to
find out who they are how they are and
how they got there
our study also made it clear that to
become a millionaire you've got to
invest wisely over a period of time and
a big part of that is getting someone in
your corner to teach you
not do it for you
my team recommends trustworthy vetted
investing pros from all over the country
we call them smart vester pros to get in
touch with the smart investor pro in
your area go to ramseysolutions.com
smart vester and start building wealth
today
that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash
smart vester
paul is in cincinnati hey paul welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave and george how are you guys
doing great how can we help
um just have a question for you i'm
hoping you can speak out of your
experience from when you and sharon hit
bottom
i'm wondering
how do i make it up to my wife for my
financial mistakes and wasteful spending
from before we started the baby steps
ah well obviously you stop
the activity yes sir right um and the
more time the more time that elapses
from the last time you were stupid the
the less she's gonna look at it
okay like in my case uh you know 30
years ago
uh
more than 30 years ago my goodness
gracious now uh 34 years ago we filed
bankruptcy
okay and we lost everything now so the
stuff that i did in that
is still inside of our marriage is still
inside of our our psyche it's still in
our spirits
but it doesn't affect her
she's not nearly as afraid
today
of me doing that same stupid thing as
she was one month after i did it
does that make sense right so time 80 is
behavior change concern yeah time is a
great healer is what i'm saying
uh as long as you don't keep doing it
right so uh but we used to you know we
used to say the joke and it wasn't
really a joke that uh we not only had an
emergency fund we had an emergency fund
for the emergency fund
because sharon was not going to be
without money ever again with little
kids because she was without money with
little kids
and uh you know she was terrified
literally it was not just afraid she was
terrified that we were going to be
homeless our our water got cut off our
electricity got cut off um you know she
was tariff and we had a brand new baby
named rachel and a toddler named denise
and so yeah it didn't she didn't she
didn't forget that in a week
right
how did you earn back her trust not
doing it again for a long period of time
not doing it again right okay
we've uh we're in baby step two right
now and we're throwing like forty five
hundred dollars per month at our debt um
on top of our regular payments and
i just you know we just started but
today i had to come to my life again
because i remembered another mistake
that i made that just hit the uh credit
card bill yes we've cut up the credit
card but i didn't see it till now
and uh
that wasn't a recent mistake it was the
it was the discovery of an old mistake
you didn't hide it from her you didn't
hide it from her
and you didn't you didn't run the debt
up last week right
no okay no sure you just didn't see the
bill until you found it the other day
and you bring it to yourself and that
shouldn't count against you
okay another thing is this we don't we
quit making decisions by ourselves
sharon and i did right we make decisions
together
and so we don't spend money
or make big financial decisions
without both of us being in agreement on
that now the definition of big as our
life has gotten big
is different
okay but uh i mean if she goes and buys
something now
that you know with our current income
it's a different version of big right
but uh but but we don't but we're not
going to do something that's going to
interfere in in the in the lot in our
lives or
have a weight that we don't discuss it
and do it together and you guys you you
and wouldn't have been doing that since
you started your relationship oh yeah i
mean i met her here at ramsey so it was
easy to be on the same page but that
level of open and honest communication i
mean that's great marriage advice and
it's great money advice and the more
honest you are and the less things she's
discovering uh the better it's going to
be for the long term and like dave said
as time goes on there's going to be more
trust that is built there which means
there's going to be less of the the
guilt and shame that you're feeling
right now which it sounds like he's he's
beating himself up over these mistakes
and i want him to look to the future the
more she sees some sacrificing wanting
to get out of debt communicating i think
this will dissipate but yeah
and back to the working together thing
that you were talking about that's
really
that's another element of it okay
because in our case i made all the
decisions i just did everything
and sharon was an innovation
she just it all happened to her
okay
and so now we do a budget
and she
is if something screws up it's half her
fault because she had a vote she knew we
were doing it if something goes bad she
does not get it i told you so anymore
because it's we did it together they're
shared and so she has a sense of
it gives her a level of trust because
she is involved in the decision making
she's speaking into the budget okay
rather than it happening to her and that
increased her trust as well so time
heals all not repeating the mistakes
obviously full disclosure
full authenticity uh lots of
communication and she now has a vote
and so then she doesn't get to
gripe if something goes wrong
you know because you you we made this
decision together this is a dumb idea i
know we did it together we were dumb
together you know and we've done some
stuff since we went bankrupt then we
look back on him and go god that was
stupid but at least we were together
stupid you know it wasn't like i did it
and then she can point her finger
because she's a genius and i'm an idiot
you know we can't do that anymore i'm
like hey we were fellow idiots in that
one your fellow geniuses in the other
one you know and that that share the
wins you share the losses yeah but
and that is the beauty of the budget we
don't talk about that enough is because
a lot of spouses like to stand in the
sidelines and throw grenades over on the
one working on the budget and trying to
get the money done well if you just got
that over there or straightened out
there stand over there on the side and
look over the fence and yell about it
instead of getting back in the middle of
it and actually fixing the line
quarterback exactly exactly it does away
with the i told you so or the grenade
throwing from the neighbor's yard or
whatever you want to call it uh you both
are making the decision these are two
grown-ups one of you doesn't get to
whine ago and my husband won't let me my
wife won't let me
it's time to be a freaking grown-up you
know
sign your name on the same line with
everybody else on this budget we
are deciding what we
are doing and it gets rid of all this
i'm your daddy i'm your mommy not your
husband or wife thing and he doesn't
have that the guy calling he's not got
any of that he's just trying to recover
from the emotions of all the mistakes
and like you said the guilt and shame
but powerful part is like financial
peace university a byproduct of that is
you get on the same page because you
have shared language and shared goals
and a lot of couples have that for the
first time
when they start doing a budget
we have had so many people going through
financial peace university that says
save their marriage and we're like dude
it was not a matter we didn't mean to
make a marriage it didn't mean to make a
marriage class but we forced them to be
in agreement we forced them to have both
have a vote to have the dignity of
speaking into their future
as a grown-up instead of being enabled
or caretaking or princesses or princes
or whatever it is it's whatever the crap
goes on in people's dysfunctional
marriages right
and so we're forcing them to back do
this together we're also forcing them to
come into agreement on what their fears
are and what their dreams are
and that will force you to have an
awesome marriage yeah and those mistakes
it's a part of your story but it doesn't
define you your bankruptcy doesn't
define you but it's a part of your story
no and so i learned not to be quite as
stupid your identity isn't stupid you've
just done some stupid stuff i got a phd
in dunb i graduated that's one less than
deloney you're almost there
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage mark
and megan are with us hey guys how are
you doing pretty well how are you doing
great welcome welcome where do you guys
live
charlotte charlotte north carolina good
to have you and how much have you paid
off
362 500
all right and how long did this take uh
just shy of seven years so about what 80
82 months got it and your range of
income during that seven years uh we
started around 180 and finished last
year around 290. excellent what do y'all
do for a living
i work for a tech services company in
doing business planning and strategy and
i'm in banking way to go guys y'all are
killing people so uh this kind of money
over seven years i'm gonna guess and say
you're weird people and paid off your
house we did you got it
a couple of weirdos awesome
it's not a lamborghini okay
great guys good job man all right well
tell us your story how did you decide to
do this how did you get plugged into the
ramsey stuff gosh um well i think it
probably started when i came out of
college um i had heard about you through
family
so i was kind of always plugged in and
then when mark and i met and started
dating and
i think we were always pretty
transparent with one another kind of
discussing finances and goals
and we just knew when we were signing up
for a big mortgage that was going to be
a big target for us to hit
and just decided let's let's go after it
we were very fortunate to enter into our
relationship
both debt-free and
less mortgage and so we just
you know centered all of our forces and
tried to fire away at it as quickly as
we could okay cool so mark you're in
banking how did all this come up with
you uh through megan so as she said we
met um and started dating she always was
kind of preaching your books a little
bit towards me and she gave me a few to
read and which i did and kind of latched
on to them and found just a lot of what
i thought was common sense in which you
you offered and just the the ability to
take that dat wipe it off and just feel
free from it was probably part of our
biggest goal
part of you had to look at this and go
this guy gets paid for this
i have to admit we did both come for
very fortunate to come from families
that i think had always instilled in us
a sense of practicality and common sense
um so i think
getting to a place of commonality and
agreement um was kind of encoded in us
from just our parents that's why yeah
very much so nothing i would say
explicit growing up but we think
observed a lot of frugal nature and i'll
call my parents a little bit it's an
unbelievable advantage though yeah yeah
yeah you came into this with a real
functional view
on how all this work and so when you saw
our stuff you're like oh yeah okay it
makes sense it did it gave us a good
structure did your banker friends think
you're weird
i don't tell them anything oh good
i didn't know nothing
yeah i like it we'll celebrate with you
even if they won't appreciate it
okay so if uh somebody finds out how old
are you guys
i'm 35 and 41. what's this house worth
about 750 to 800. yeah it's it's
skyrocketed
700 it's 750 ish 750 okay and how much
in retirement
oh gosh
six
six six ish yeah okay so you're baby
steps millionaires yeah yeah you did it
and you know your young ones you did it
early well done thank you this works it
works it works was it was it easier than
you thought or harder than you thought
uh
i think it was easier simply because we
were always in communication and and
could talk through anything that was
challenging um
and so the issues where i would want to
go faster which was usually the case um
i think mark would kind of temper that
and i think anything that seemed like a
hurdle to overcome was very much
tempered by that open line of dialogue
and being um candid with one another so
i think it was easier because of a
healthy marriage
yes very much so yes and you know strong
upbringing but yeah yeah that's awesome
so we probably had a goal of paying it
off in five we extended a little bit
tried to a little live in the now um you
know do some house upgrades stuff like
that but i always always made sure we
had the money for it versus taking on
more debt yeah and we had a couple of
kiddos along the way yeah how many kids
have we got down um so we currently have
three and number four will be here next
month all right very good
debt-free baby that's right that's right
fun how does it feel to have a payment
in the world fantastic it's amazing
sense of freedom did that catch you off
guard more than you thought or less than
you thought
uh i don't know that it's quite sunk in
i mean we just paid this off in april
and so we're starting to see that
compounding effect of the mortgage
payment not going out and um and not
extra on it right right um and so that's
been i think it's starting to settle in
and certainly as we are preparing for
this um addition to our family i think
that's been very comforting yeah yeah so
i mean you're sitting on 300k a year and
no payments right you got some margin
yeah yeah what's something big you want
to do soon oh go overseas uh overseas
get a good trip in yeah yeah after baby
is is big enough that you can lose yeah
that's right absolutely very cool well
congratulations thank you we're very
very proud of you what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
i would say just just common sense live
within your means it's it's not that
difficult
yeah he makes it sound so easy
not that hard 65 jobs i just barely
almost died
it's just common sense live on lesson
you make
not rocket science that's great no we
mentioned it earlier i think the
communication was also big for at least
from my perspective just being able to
talk through and um align on things very
cool great job guys very proud of you we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you thank you you are one obviously
and uh all you can give it away if you
want and inspire somebody else and same
thing with the book total money makeover
and the same thing with a one-year
membership to financial peace university
uh we'll get you signed up for all of
that and it's just our way of saying
thank you for making the trip over here
congratulations on the new baby thank
you congrats on being a hundred percent
debt-free did you bring any of the
kiddos with you we've got two of them
here all right
cuties oh here we go
what are their names and agents charlie
here for their twins oh and louie here
as well charlie and louie charlie and
louie the twins four years old they're
beautiful shout out to big sister emmy
who's not here yeah okay didn't make the
trip all right good stuff all right mark
and megan charlie and louie and baby on
the way
363 000 paid off house and everything
in seven years baby steps millionaires
making 180 to 290. count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two one
we're debt-free
is how it's done baby
[Applause]
man
love it love it love it so proud of you
guys
very very very well done
you know george when we talk about
um
personal finances 80
behavior
uh only 20 head knowledge
i often think about when my grandmother
was alive she was in a small town and
had grown up in that small town third
generation and knew everybody
and she would say things like well
so-and-so is from a good family
and i at first i kind of thought when i
was a little kid i kind of thought
she was talking about like they were
wealthy
or they were
prominent or they were prestigious and
she was being like
trying to be stuck up country club or
something you know
and i as i got to grew as i grew up and
got to know her better what she was
saying was they were a family of
character
the family was functional they were a
good
family
it wasn't about money exactly and and
but it ends up being
about money these two came from a good
family to where for them this was just
automatic
they didn't have to like relearn because
they were raised by wolves
they didn't have to they didn't have to
they didn't have to be re-parented
because they weren't parented the first
time and so when we talk to you guys all
the time about changing your family tree
it's more than just leaving
somebody you know your children who are
the village idiot with two million
dollars
it's the idea that you're changing your
child so they're not the village idiot
you become the good family you're
changing the dna of your family exactly
you're changing the behavior and the
character and the flow and the
and who they are and how they relate so
that when they get married they're these
two that's way more powerful than an
inheritance it is they're inheriting
character and then on top of that throw
five or ten million dollars now you got
world changers
that that's changing your family
you know that's a good
family these people are their mom and
dad
both of them good people impressive
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs
25 4
remove the dross from silver and a
silversmith can produce
a vessel
theodore roosevelt said nothing in this
world is worth having or worth doing
unless it means effort pain and
difficulty
well that's pleasant but it's true yeah
teddy understood many many years ago
yeah so our real estate reality check is
tonight a live stream for those of you
listening
live or close to live this is july 14th
thursday night at 7 00 p.m uh we've got
just under 100 000 folks already
registered to watch it it is a free live
stream the real estate reality check
we're going to go through we're actually
going to have a low class classroom time
on you know what makes up the real
estate market where the actual data
lands and then rachel cruz george
campbell and i
will address this whole subject and uh
you know we're gonna address things
we've been hearing from you uh here on
the air and george and rachel read some
of the comments and stuff in there
always danger social media which i see
you don't have to i don't i'm not gonna
read them it's not
just it's not cause i'm stuck up or
something it just i can't put that much
negativity in my system and still walk
around
it's just there's a lot of emotion and
there's a lot of there's a lot of
relationship and and so we're gonna
address that we're gonna help folks with
it tonight just go to
ramseysolutions.com and you can sign up
for it if you still are if you're
hearing this in time
i hope you are and uh we'll try to make
it available for some of you that don't
hear it on time but uh i don't know if
we'll be able to or not it is a live
stream tonight we know that at 7 p.m
central time 8 pm eastern time and it is
100
free
all right let's check with cody and
boise hi cody how are you
good how are you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
good um i just so i want to preface this
first by like i i feel like i'm almost
going behind my wife's back and calling
to talk about this
um so here we go like me and my wife
we've kind of been starting our
debt-free journey here the last i want
to say a year so
been a little bit davis we get really
good and then kind of fall back but we
fall back together
my wife wants to be a motivational
speaker so she's been really
trying to get on that gun
um
and i want to support her with
everything i can
um she came to me a couple days ago
saying that she had a phone call with
some people from the speaker lab
said it was a free call
just to kind of see where she's going
see what they could do to help her
after the call she gave me a call and
said don't be mad
i just spent five thousand dollars
why wouldn't you be mad
yeah of course you're going to be mad
you guys were in agreement on what you
were doing and then she just got on
there and got sold
of course you're going to be mad why
wouldn't you be mad
well
we we we don't ever spend even 20 30
without talking to each other yeah so i
mean she just bought a freaking car man
yes
so how did she pay for this
so like i said we've been davis we've
been paying a credit card off we had the
credit card down cancel the sale just
call them and tell them you're not doing
it
she did it in increments she put well i
wouldn't say she paid eight or five
thousand dollars she did nine hundred
dollars yesterday and it just kept
paying me just tell them you're not
doing it i know those guys tell them
tell them we said to refund them do you
really yeah they're local guys
really
i just looked it up i thought i
recognized that name
and so uh yeah i i think if they're
reasonable people you say hey listen
we're on the ramsay plan we're trying to
get a debt we didn't talk about this we
really can't afford this right now
and see what they say there's no
promises you know their business but
i think they might be willing to work
with you on this
i don't think they have a choice to be
honest with you i think you can just
cancel the sale or you say i'll talk to
the credit card company we'll have it
you know
refunded that way but
yeah this is i mean this bigger than
this this is financial infidelity and we
got to get on the same page and there's
no more dave ish if we're going to do
this thing you're not going to get any
progress if you take one step forward
three steps back
so we have to really go what's at the
root that's causing us to fall back time
and time again do we really want this
what is our why do we have a strong
enough why what is our vision for the
family why are we trying to get out of
debt
uh but this is a reset you guys need to
have as a couple
okay
i get she has dreams and she wants to be
a motivational speaker but right now
we've got to focus on getting out of
debt so that we can make a lot of money
speaking i've never paid anybody five
thousand dollars to get to learn how to
do it
yeah because
when she talked to me she was really
excited about it and then they gave her
these promises of well we'll give you
this many leads we'll help you build
your website we'll do this do that
and a free call just turned into a lot
of money well they're great sales people
apparently yeah it's okay if
the their service is valid you're not in
a position to buy their service today
you're too broke
okay
and she's not in a position to to spend
five thousand dollars to start a small
business today
you're broke right
and so we can you know
so what she needs to do is continue to
work on her craft
continue to grow
continue to get reps listen there's only
one thing at the end of the day that
causes people to be world-class speakers
uh and that is just well two things
studying your craft ongoing
and reps
lots of reps
step up on the stage and talk step up on
the stage and talk step up on the stage
and talk and it's not a class and it's
not a website and it's not leads it's
reps
so a class a website leads all that'll
work but
um
you know
cody this sale needs to be canceled uh
for lots of reasons one is you can't
afford it two is she violated ural's
trust and she should be ashamed about
that
instead of like don't be mad
you know yes i'm mad you know you dad
come right i'm mad
you know you 5 000 from my listen man
i'm a multi-millionaire my wife doesn't
spend five thousand dollars i don't
spend five thousand dollars talking to
her on something like this now we
obviously have transactions at the
business here that sharon's not involved
in on a daily basis and she's happy for
it but in terms of being yeah she
doesn't want to screw with it but but in
terms of things that sharon and i are
doing on our personal life i don't book
trips without a personal hey i booked a
trip for us to go on vacation i would go
over like a dad gum lead balloon yeah
whether you're a millionaire or not this
is a huge financial deal you just you
just make major decisions together and
you don't
throw a grenade over the fence and go
don't be mad i'm sorry you're going i'm
mad yeah you did come right i'm mad
you know it just doesn't work that way
it doesn't work that way so no i and
then george is right the biggest issue
at the core of this whole thing is the
two of you've gotta decide what you're
gonna be
you know this you've been screwing
around with the edges of this thing are
you really gonna get real and do it or
not
and get yourself out of debt and we're
not trying to sell you anything
we just we just want to sell you on
changing your life
transforming your life that's one of the
beauties of cutting up the credit card
and being broke is you don't have a
choice you can't go spend five thousand
dollars if you wanted to
hey there's an idea
one you know if there's a debit card and
there's not five thousand dollars in the
checking account you don't accidentally
spend it
and go don't be mad you don't have that
as an option
and that's why it's fun to spend your
own money because you make decisions
differently there it is yeah there's one
angle
but i'll i'll reach out to them myself
if i have to to remedy this situation
for cody oh that's not cool well
georgia's got pull i've got so much pull
around here dave you have no idea those
people
so uh also make sure you get cody's uh
phone number if they don't me if they
want to cancel the sale which is what
they should do uh big george is going to
step in for him okay thank you for
calling me big dave it's the first and
the last it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen
gonna happen he's gonna throw his weight
around his considerable girth 130 pounds
getting thrown around dave be careful
watch out world
oh boy well dave it's almost game time
i'm pumped for this event in just a few
hours we're doing this thing it is man
i'm sorry team's been working so hard
we've been working hard on all of our
content to make sure that we deliver
people what they asked for and i'll just
go ahead and tell you i'm not gonna say
anything about tonight but uh you know
we were walking through looking at the
production values and everything earlier
and uh uh doing a walkthrough on the
whole thing and the quality of
production that ramsay is putting out
these days i'm so proud they want up at
every time and i'm a video team the what
this is gonna look like on camera it's
beyond 4k i didn't even know that
existed dave it's it's world class
you'll see the sweat on our brow tonight
so tune in ramsay solutions.com reality
check can't wait for it there it is game
on
that puts us out in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you